right so I have a very clear deal with
my brain as a third party my brain is a
third party so it's allowed to give me
only two types of thought the third it
gets kicked out of my room right and
comes back with a better thought so
my brain can bring me a joyful thought
or a useful thought mmm
right if the if the if the thought is
joyful we will go along with it if it's
not I will stop it right so every
morning I wake up and my brain will tell
me I'm not making this up I love that
boy so much every morning I will wake up
and my brain will say iodide and every
morning I will wake up and deliberately
say no brain and he lived and he lived
is the same thought but when I when I
remind my brain that had he lived I get
21 and a half incredible years of all of
the wonderful moments that we spent
together it's the same thought like Ali
died but the idea died would bring his
image in the end intensive care Oh
mm-hmm
I don't want that image because it's
useless it's the 21 years of bliss that
you had and then what you're doing with
it now that the drives that the staff
use the same thought but there's a
different outcomes and the outcome is so
different the outcome is so different
well when you when you lead your brain
as a third party suddenly your brain
does amazing things so same applies to
useful thoughts huh
when I Lee died my brain started to say
every single minute for the next four
hours it had one thought
repeating over and over and over you
should have driven him to another
hospital until I allowed out loud I told
myself what can I do with that brain
mm-hmm
what can I do with that thought can I go
back and drive him to another hospital
now can you please go back and find me a
better thought just like I'm talking to
a third party a friend who's constantly
complaining right and and and my brain
was like okay let me think about that
right four days later it came back and
said hey what about if we share his
model with ten million people and make
them happy what would would that be a
good thought yes like yeah I'll take
that
let's do it
right that's a great thought and does it
bring him back it does not bring him
back understand this you have a contract
with your brain to not allow needless
suffering absolutely don't waste my life
and by the way I learned that as an
executive right so people would walk
into my room and complain and you know
being courteous I listened for the first
10 minutes and then after 10 minutes
what do good executives say they say
okay what's good about this situation
right or what can we do about it what do
you want me to change what actions can
we take right and once you do that the
person on the other side now that they
vented a little they will say well you
know but I also like this and maybe you
shouldn't change that and but maybe we
should do this great that's the kind of
thought that we want incessant thinking
is useless
it's just complaining